the hypocrisy of your father I mean Not
only was he living off your mother
making your life horrible the shocking
Revelation that he had a whole second
family going somewhere yeah I get off
the plane at LaGuardia Airport
and some little kid comes up to me and
jumps in my arms I had no idea who he
was
and my father was right behind him and I
knew clearly because that was the case
he knew the kid I said who is this he
said little brother
just like that just like that no no
wanting no anything no wanting no
anything and then he took me in the car
and when he took us in the car to drive
me home Knowles
um
put me in the back seat because somebody
was in the front seat and that was his
mistress
and when he took when when the mistress
was in the car and I saw that I knew at
that moment what this was and I was like
holy [ __ ] this is because all I could
think about was my mother I grew up on
203rd Street in the Hollis and he
dropped me off right on the corner of
111th Avenue and he said don't tell your
mother
that you had it that I had anybody with
you and I worked I walked in the house
and the first thing my mother asked me
after she said hello
she said your father dropped you off I
said yes she said
was he by himself
and I said
yes
and it was the only lie
I've ever told my mother I've never
harbored animosity towards him over me
it was the treatment of my mother
that I could not take when you started
to get successful yeah and and really
make some serious dough yeah it suddenly
he tried to change the history between
the two of you you damn right he did he
most certainly did a matter of fact it
happened one of the days happened in the
dining room of my mother's house
I would tell you this is about 10 years
ago about 10 years ago so he's
complaining because Christmas comes by
you know because Christmas comes and
goes and my mother
I sent her on a cruise to Europe my
father I bought him the club remember
that club that you put on your steering
wheel for the car yeah so your car
doesn't get stolen exactly right in the
club right I won the club and he was
like what the hell is this and he was
and he was like why didn't I get why
didn't I get you know the kind of gift
you gave your mother I said cause you
ain't mom
and so that led to an argument in front
of my Uncle Freddie who's now deceased
as well
um and Uncle Freddie was right there and
my father tried to tell me what kind of
a father he was and you don't know what
the hell you talking about it you don't
know what I've done and I went in on him
and I said you did this in 1978 you did
this in 1983 you did that in 1988 you
did that in 1991. my Uncle Freddie
looked at him and said by soul
shut the [ __ ] up
your son is a journalist he knows what
he's talking about he can Chronicle
everything you've done you've got no
shot to win this argument shut the [ __ ]
up